my buddy from EMM QB he is albert prayer
back here in the Rich Eisen show how are
you Albert that was a heck of a lead-in
there's that nu TZ
yeah somebody on our youtube.com slash
Rich Eisen show livestream where people
can watch us now live every day
basically said we just showed superstar
page kicking del Teufel and Brockman in
the nuts a few weeks ago that somebody
should do that to Jim Dolan and I kind
of you know I don't have a I don't
advocate for that sort of thing but you
could probably understand why it's crazy
alright brother let's get into it walk
down the teams that are interested in
Brady as you and I are sitting here
right now Albert Brown yeah you know III
don't know the market is all that hot I
was just tell you you need a lot of
conditions in place to really want to go
after them maybe want to blow up the
offense need to be willing to need to be
willing to kind of put yourself on a
two-year timetable need to be willing to
look and see in the near future where
rebuild is going to be coming and he you
need to be willing to put talent around
them so I think there's a limited number
team and center that are interested you
know the Patriots are interested in
bringing back the Titans are interested
but they're also interested in their own
quarterback Ryan Tannehill who they're
going to make a decision on over the
next week and then you know at the
Raiders and the Chargers will also kick
the tires on it I know they're
investigating the possibility of it what
it would take etcetera etc so there's
the four teams that I sort of put in the
group right now we always have a
surprise me field all remember this but
the Broncos sort of came out of nowhere
I'm Peyton Manning a few in 2012 so
there's probably someone lurking out
there but those are the four teams that
put front right not about the 49ers
albert is there any smoke at all I mean
I talked to several people in that
organization um and I just tell you I I
did not sense that there was a great
chance that it's gonna happen now maybe
something changes I don't know and I'm
not trying to shoot down what anybody
else is saying but that possibility
seems somewhat remote right now they're
really happy with where they are not
just today but
if you look at what what their next five
years are so going to look like that
doesn't mean they're 100% in on Jimmy
Garoppolo over the next five years I
actually think Jimmy Garoppolo could be
on the clock this year because you know
Kirk Cousins is going to be a free agent
next year I'm just telling you III don't
think that they're of a mind right now
to sort of go all in on the next two
years and just have massive uncertainty
beyond that because they're really happy
with where they are right and I know
they're really happy with where they are
right now but it's crazy man
at some point the age is gonna have to
catch up but at some point we also need
to stop saying how old the man is to
that that he is still Tom Brady and you
know he could take any team that's close
and put him over the top so why not the
team that was seven minutes away he's
still I mean yeah he's still a good
player I mean I and look I think a lot
of the stuff that went wrong last year
was if it's always around him
you know I but the Patriots got old in a
lot of spots at the end of last year you
know that sort of brings him up an
internal debate New England with that
organization where they're asking
themselves with so much age on defense
um agent offense to Edelman 34 do we
need to blow it up right now and if you
don't blow it up and you're not bringing
it back you know so yeah I mean I think
certainly just still play and he could
certainly be that guy for some team you
have to be right on the precipice and
I'm telling you he takes great pride in
his personal performance as much as he
loves winning he also watched it you
know play really well the past couple of
years and that was what frustrated him
last year was his personal personal
performance suffered from what was
around him so you're gonna have to have
an appealing situation to him too and so
you know you look at what the Chargers
have they'd have to fix their offensive
line you know look at what the Titans
have are they going to be able to bring
back to Eric Henry you look at what the
Raiders have if you're going to sit with
Jon Gruden you know there are questions
in each of those places and so it's
really interesting there's not a perfect
scenario out there for him and I I've
been saying this since December rich I
mean I think what could wind up creating
you know his return to New England is
the two sides what
at each other and and and and their best
option is one another well what do you
make of Tom Kern's latest report that
the connection between Belichick and
Brady went down yesterday on Tuesday and
did not go well what are you what do you
make of of all because bill was all
business like you know like he's uh he's
an impractical joker usually you know I
mean what do you make about all that
yeah I would tell you like my experience
having been around at organizations for
fifteen years
don't bill isn't big on negotiating you
know bill will look at each player
coldly and say this is what I think
you're worth and it's not in a mean way
it's just you know this is where we see
your value right if you know you see it
the way we do then and we can make that
work and that that's sort of the way
they approach free agency to like if you
look at the way that they go into free
agency at the combine they may talk to
23 agents and put values out there on
those 20 players knowing that most of
those letters are going to get more like
thinking okay two or three and two or
three those guys are going to come back
so we're gonna get really good deals
just the way that they approach roster
building and so my guess is that that
bill gave him a very cold calculated
like this is the way we see it right now
and you know you could certainly see if
you're Tom Brady as logical and some of
that stuff might be if you're Tom Brady
and you put 20 years to the organization
you have six ring and that franchisee
literally worth multiples of what it was
worth in large part because of you you
know you can see where you take some of
that stuff personally and so that's what
this is all going to come down to was
you know are you willing to come back on
his terms Belichick willing to come back
on his terms and whether or not those
set the terms could match up and I
haven't heard personally the things
didn't go well last night but it but if
they didn't go well and that's probably
a pretty bad time no I know but there's
still so much time man I mean there's
there's Tim we're two weeks away from
this decision having to been made and
then we'll see what what Brady does get
an actual offer I mean everybody could
say we're interested we're interested
we're interested
and then it actually comes time to brass
tacks it and the details come out from
either contract length to money or more
importantly for Tom Brady roster or
comfort comfort within the system either
scheme or actually whoo-hoo you know is
t b12 system is allowed and in the
building in a way that maybe others or
not I mean there's a lot of stuff that
needs to be hammered out that's the
timeframe and that's the way I see it
what about you and the system thing like
don't underrate the system thing I mean
like you remember like when Peyton
Manning went to Denver I mean like Mike
McCoy and Adam GaSe and all those guys
work with them and basically were able
to reconstruct his system in Denver and
they knew they were going to have him
for four years so they knew that it
would work for four years this is a
little different and you know I can give
you kind of an example you know and I I
think this is why I think it'd be almost
impossible to rebuild what he has
language the amount of institutional
knowledge they're like they'll have
something called Oakland say right and
you know young players say well why do
you guys call that Oakland well because
back in 2008 we ran against the Raiders
and scored a touchdown on it
and so I you know to have that level of
institutional knowledge where josh has
worked with with Tom for almost 20 years
bill has worked with Tom for almost 20
years that system is Tom Brady system
it's been bastardized in a good way
where it's really form-fitted for Tom
Brady is he gonna be comfortable going
somewhere else
I mean rich I'm telling you I've been
told stories where he sits in that
quarterback room studying defenses and
he'll be looking at the offense on the
screen and he'll say what the hell is
that what are we trying to do what just
I think he's very particular on what he
thinks is good offensively what he
thinks works offensively and I think
it's really really hard to recreate that
somewhere else
Albert Breer here on the Rich Eisen show
give me a surprise that's gonna happen
in the next two weeks give me a good one
give me a good one I spent well it
wouldn't be a surprise if Gruden brought
in competition for Derek Carr would it
that doesn't count as one I mean like it
depends on who that is who is who's the
competition if I am
get out of Tennessee Tom Brady lands
there I wouldn't be surprised if Ryan
Tannehill goes to Oakland maybe even as
their replacement for Derek Carr so that
would be one you know I did the Jamis
you know both situations got sideways
Jameis wanted a lot of money and the
Bucks were turned off by that you know
rivers are the cult is something that's
been discussed a lot something that will
be surprising here's one don't be
surprised if it running back if Kenyan
Drake who is traded in midseason for
basically nothing right mmm if Kenyan
Drake gets more than Melvin Gordon how's
that on the free agent market on the
free agent market I would say it's
something better for you that's kind of
like no no no it's not at all no no no
look look Albert I'm asking you to make
some sort of prediction or no that that
wouldn't be too so that would be
somewhat sprite what are we hearing
about Gordon where he might wind up what
do you think on that that's on the real
market his markets a little tougher
because like I said McCain's ranked
somebody who brings value in the past
means more of a 21st century back
Gordon's like an older school back and
so you know like there's I just his
market is gonna be like does Derrick
Henry leave Tennessee could he be a
replacement in that sort system I think
it's gonna wind up being something like
that and I would tell you this like I
think you know and you were just as a
combine so you saw these kids up close
you know I one thing I have heard is
that it might be hard for some receivers
and running backs to get paid both of
those positions are really really good
like receiver if you're one of these if
you're one of these teams are you gonna
go pay Amari Cooper 18 million or are
you gonna draft one in the second round
you may be able to start for you and
make less than - 2 million bucks how
about how about this hour you could we
could be sit here and say that no free
agent running back and no free agent
wide receiver will make more next year
than Tony Romo
that's I like that I think that's
entirely possible but it is a fire which
is crazy it is nuts in terms of you know
an announcer making more as a announcer
than he is it a player and we're talking
about an NFL quarterback on top of all
of it but yeah I mean seeing a wide
receiver a rich yes it's a media guy now
though so that's a good promise right
rising tide lifts all boats yeah that's
the theory let's see it put in a
practice brother we'll see how that
works okay and and before I let you go
what is the latest on the collective
bargaining agreement you know you and I
spent many a day on NFL Network together
me in the Los Angeles Total Access to do
you on a Washington DC or New York City
street corner live that was 10 years ago
for crying out loud next year like I
know time flies Albert when we have
labor peace so the question is is what's
happening here because it does factor
into tags and it does factor into
whether there's more or less pie for dak
and other players as well what do you
have for me on that front god me and you
did full show yeah I like right now the
NFL and NFL PA lawyers the lawyers for
both sides are pretty together the
language for what's going to be a
300-page document within a few days I
think hopefully by the end of the week
maybe early next week that document will
go out to players and then they're gonna
give the players some time to digest it
and after that the players are going to
vote on it and you know we're sort of in
a key stretch here because again slpas
rep meetings are next week be AC 11th in
miami and they're gonna be liking a new
president so if this thing doesn't go
through we can have a pretty major
problem in our hands because then the
players are going to be sitting there
and they're gonna say to themselves well
what do we have to share ourselves for
we have to prepare ourselves for the
possibility there's going to be a
lockout 2021 and so at that point you
would think that they would elect a
president would probably be a little bit
more of a fighter which I mean of course
could change the dynamic of the whole
thing altogether and so we're in a
critical stage here you know III the
feeling like
Richard no League both both sides like
we really feel like they put together a
strong deal you know but certainly
there's some dissension in the ranks of
the players and it'll be interesting to
see if the rank-and-file vote against
this because one of the key parts of the
deal the Mandate of the NFLPA was go
take care of the average player well the
average player in the NFL makes the
minimum and about half of the membership
maybe or more than after the membership
is on the minimum and those guys would
each get an immediate $100,000 raise
with this and so I just even if you know
the Executive Committee and the player
reps are against this it's very hard for
me to see where so many guys in the
minimum being basically offered a
six-figure raise right away would vote
though so which will we know about first
the CBA is accepted or rejected or Tom
Brady's contractual status I think will
probably I mean so be March 16 to the
Champaran period March 18th at the
beginning of creation yes yeah I mean if
the CBA if the CBA is still in flux at
that point I would think that they would
push back the beginning of the lead year
so we'll say CBA first that's what
happened in 2006 by the way you may
remember I believe they pushed back the
start of the league year there to
accommodate the completion of CBA so the
CBA is not done by the beginning aleady
right they push it back where - well
that gives more time for the Brady
decision because the newly year is going
on the witching hour that's more that's
more that's more oxygen for everybody to
discuss this thing and speculate on this
thing and yeah I mean Marseille teams
can't get here fast
to be honest but let's right around the
corner brother good to see you in
Indianapolis thanks for the call Albert
right back at unit salver prayer